yes thank you all for coming
this is a very nice turnout for a Friday
Friday morning I'm Gary Tomlinson by the
way the director there would be
amenities center I didn't say that for
either in either of my introductions for
the last two days not because I think I
need no introduction but simply because
I forgot but I am Gary Tomlinson at any
rate welcome back this is the final
event of our Tanner lectures this year a
roundtable discussion of Depeche
chakravarthy's wonderful presentations
over the last two days
the panelists this morning the panelists
this morning include depeche himself of
course already introduced to you I won't
introduce them again they include also
and you will forgive me if I keep these
introductions brief so as to get right
down to business
Daniel Lord Smail professor of history
and current chair of that department at
Harvard University Dan's expertise
reaches from the Middle Ages back
through human history over the longest
DeRay of his several books his on deep
history and the brain of 2008 was a
bracing thought experiment in breaking
down the borders between human and
natural histories an experiment that he
has followed up and developed on in more
recent work YG Dimmick the William
Lampson professor of English and
American Studies here at Yale writes on
American literature's and their
interactions with law science philosophy
and global literature's she is one of
the directors of Yale's literature the
arts and the environment colloquium
michael warner is the seymour k knox
professor of english and american
studies at Yale he brings social and
critical theory to bear on many topics
in American literature and has been
particularly concerned in recent years
with issues of secularism
and the public sphere he is presently
teaching a wide-ranging seminar entitled
inventing the environment in the
Anthropocene the general order of events
this morning will be as follows we're
going to hear first from down Smail
briefly depeche will have an opportunity
to respond to some of the questions and
issues that Dan raises then we'll hear
from Michael again briefly and and and
depeche will will respond again then
from y Qi and de peche will respond once
more and at that point we will we will
open it up to the to the discussants
more broadly and more flexibly and more
fluidly and finally we will lay a little
bit later on open it up to questions and
comments
from the floor the last thing I will say
is that at the end of it all which
depending upon how it goes will be about
noon or 12:15 at the latest there will
be snacks sandwiches coffee and and and
cookies and things like that in room 108
at the end of the hall everybody is
invited so let me turn it over to Dan to
start live without further ado we didn't
bite Jean and Michel we didn't actually
talk about whether we want to stand up
for our very brief remarks did you have
a feeling about this yes yeah and then I
can exert my stomach muscles just thank
you so much to to Gary for the
invitation to come here it's a real
honor de peche was speaking yesterday
about having about the idea of the dream
the of doing at an election for me I
think the chance of doing a comment on a
Tanner lecture is equally glorious the
these remarks are really meant to as
gary said meant to be sort of
conversation starters I have a question
and have a parable but I'd like to begin
by with just some thoughts about the
aesthetics of the lectures there's a
beautiful aesthetic in a depression of
the universe in the teacup and over the
course of two days you were bringing us
into all of the many things that one can
find in that particular teacup the the
sort of the energy states of the
molecules of thermal thermal factors
that are rising up the flavor compounds
interface between the milk and the tea
and those kinds of things and the teacup
of course was that single word common in
expression common and differentiated
responsibilities and the point here was
that we understood the T of the
differentiated but the common was empty
and needed to be composed and as we got
to the end of your remarks on the second
day I think we were always - I was on
the edge of my seat because I was
wondering if as he had gone into the
extraordinary things you can find in
that teacup how are you how are you
gonna bring it back to the common and
you did it in this in at least in the
way that I read it
a really beautiful way through the
political namely that there's a politics
of the differentiated and we know what
only two well because it's the politics
of paralysis but can there be a politics
of the common because there's no
infrastructure there's no limits to how
far are those politics must extend they
might go out to harmful microbes at the
very extent of it
there's no ethics available for us and
there's and there's no history and as a
historian this is where I find myself
engaging most so you have this
relationship with big history which at
once is welcoming this is the falling
into big history but at the other sense
is you have a strong sense of the
inadequacies of this so on the one hand
big history sets itself up as an
alternative cosmology but those
histories are told on scales as you say
the human mind simply cannot fathom and
I was going to give you some more proof
of this if you needed it I was reading
some work on the the way which people
estimate large numbers and it turns out
that half of Americans if asked to place
1 million between one thousand and one
billion will put it halfway hmm between
that's as I said I know that you needed
proof of this but but this is a proof of
the difficulty we have of dealing with
scale so running through your two
lectures is this powerful distinction
between Homo and anthropos and at one
point you use a tectonic metaphor you
speak of the fault line that runs
through homo and anthropos the two
figures of the human and in a sense if
you didn't follow this metaphor but one
can think of these two plates that are
not coming together in this grinding
crash that is a book called
consciousness comes from now you could
have chosen different frames or
metaphors and so here's my question is
this the right intellectual architecture
for framing the homo Etha prose
split and to explain this question I'm
out offer you the parable of a cow
so I was spending some time just poking
around on other on cows and digestion in
the last few days and let me let me let
you know what I came up with that dairy
cows are responsible for producing 30 to
50 liters of gas per hour it's a mixture
of carbon dioxide and methane which of
course are greenhouse gases and it turns
out that in global emissions of
greenhouse gases cattle are responsible
for 18% of it now here's the question
who is responsible for that gas now
running through my head was this a kind
of an African folk tale and what I had
this whole dialogue which I won't give
you because you can imagine yourself was
all the parts of the cow arguing who was
responsible for the gas the brain the
hooves the teeth the tail they all say
in this debate it is not our fault it is
the fault of the rumen it is the rumens
fault for producing all this gas we are
not to blame but the other barnyard
animals looking on the cow said no it's
all of you the cow all of your organs
and your limbs share this responsibility
in common now in the mean in the
meantime with what is the rumen saying
the rumen is saying no no no I'm not
responsible I'm merely the habitat for
microbes and it is they who produced the
gas and it turns out that there's
between one to ten billion bacteria per
milliliter of stomach fluid in the rumen
so there's a hell of a lot of microbes
and the microbes in turn and you can see
how this would go would say well
actually no it's only a part of us who
is responsible for this now if we choose
to start at the molecular level and then
we move up the orders of magnitude as we
move up actors come into view a microbe
a rumen a cow a feedlot global
capitalism but as we move up entities
that appeared as singular actors at one
level resolved as mere components in the
tissue of new
so they cease to be active it's a
fractal pattern hmm because there's
self-similarity all across the orders of
magnitude so here's my question rhythm
we phrased why a metaphor of faultlines
or binary divisions there's a very
binary division almost a cartesian
division that you've set up as the
intellectual architecture that
fundamental metaphor that runs through
why that division is supposed to a
metaphor of a fractal would it be
possible to recompose the homo and
anthropos through the frame of the
fracked and if you did then homo would
resolve itself as the figure of the
human that is visible in the debates
that go on inside the cow and the alpha
post in turn would see the cow whose
entire organism in common is responsible
for its admissions now I can anticipate
one of your objections I know you're
writing this down as we see which is
this isn't this just real Sony and
Concilium where everything is
subordinate to to something higher up
ultimately to the things like physics
and I what I want to say here before you
formulate this too much is this it's
actually a false analogy that a better
analogy is found in physics where the
strong force on the one hand and gravity
on the other hand operate in separate
orders of magnitude that appropriate to
them and have no relevance outside that
order so it's not a question of
dominance of political dominance of one
of a higher orbit of analysis over lo
and this is simply a question of orders
of explanation that are appropriate to
the orders of magnitude so if we accept
the lessons of the parable of the cow
then responsibility can be assembled and
disassembled as one travels across the
scales of observation so de peche is
model I think your model so like a
mecca's Q where it's the same thing that
is flipping in and out of different
states depending on how you how you look
at it that kind of model disappears in
favor of a historical optics that
operate at different scales of
observation where actors and tensions
and responsibilities vanish and reappear
as we move across orders of magnitude
so I see this as a sort of a friendly
amendment for some of the architecture
as we were speaking earlier it also has
to do with what I what I wonder about
the palimpsest of your thinking over the
five or ten years that you've been
working on it whether there's elements
of ways of thinking that are no longer
appropriate to the framework that you've
actually developed here like I'd love to
hear you talk more about this well thank
you very much then I mean for you know
characteristically both generous and
generously critical comments which is
exactly what one one's and means and so
again what we do in conversation is
sometimes in trying to protect our
individual intellectual projects we
translate the propositions of another
project into the language of your own
project whatever right and so let me
talk about the fault line the mine at
the beginning with binary I'm beginning
with binary I always think of as very as
the first step in thinking I mean I mean
Hegel's logic is all about making
distinctions first-order distinctions
which then he himself would dissolve
right but without first-order
distinctions as he said all cows the
black at night so in a way and as you
know mathematically a binary can be
converted into other orders so a binary
is not an not an essentially structure
in that sense but where I begin from and
where I and something I come back to and
it's what I'm trying to problematize not
being a natural science person and not
being doing natural not doing natural
science for the sake of doing natural
science so the stakes in the project for
me come out of the way in which as I
said I was jolted
into an awareness of the geological and
biological kind of colliding with my
sense of the historical with my sense of
the human historical and the fact that
him that's happening in as I said in
living memory in the over the span of
you know one or two generations
I would you think that a new geological
epoch can be dated from 1945 the reason
being that if future geologists come and
look at this planet then the order of
difference between the Industrial
Revolution and 1945 will not matter
because it's 1945 when they will find
geo you know geologically synchronous
evidence of the changes now so my shock
really was what I was calling being
thrown falling into was really a jolt to
my political consciousness and that
political consciousness had already been
involved in an argument with the lateral
framework in which it was very clear
that that the that the logical cognitive
criticism of the inheritance of European
natural philosophy you know which from
the from Cartesian times you know not
just the mind-body distinction but in
the experiment in optics and all of
those things resulted in to resulted in
the creation of disciplines which
artificially carved up nature into
physics and chemistry but this
artificial carving up gave European
powers initially and everybody later but
tremendous capacity to manipulate the
empirical world and this is what created
the desire in everybody to modernize I
mean the first fascination in the
history of Asian nations with Europe was
to do with military technology and by
minn trajectory I not only mean weapons
but even discipline
I mean the 18th century European
mercenaries who couldn't find jobs in
Europe so kind of second-rate
mercenaries we're all finding jobs in
India I'm trying to modernize armies of
Indian princes and and
eighteenth-century descriptions by
Indian Muslim gentlemen going to England
and looking at a cotton mill and being
mesmerised by the discipline of the
machinery this visually mesmerized by so
many arms of the machine working
together in a particular rhythm almost
sort of you know you could read Marx's
description of how the Machine
appropriates and builds the rhythm of
the animal body first and then the human
body into its own rhythm and it was as
though these this 18th century gentleman
who I am I have in mind was completely
mesmerized by the visual sight of it so
in a sense I begin from a world that had
been created by this artificial carving
up of nature into disciplines into the
scientific disciplines you know so that
even in high school when I read science
you had to know why physics was
different from chemistry right and even
as I was saying that climate change is
about bringing physics geology biology
together right so in a way you're making
the distinction and then dissolving them
trying to explain something like Earth
System science or whatever so in some
ways I so my historiography came from
that perception of the world made
available to modernizing elites
including critics of modernizers
throughout the world who all somehow
wanted the material benefits that came
out of those distinctions in terms of
human longevity our you know the
capacity to sustain populations were
longtime so Indian population until 1947
remain static at 300 million which is
exactly the number of gods we have meant
to have so there was a time when we had
more birds than people and then by 47 we
had the same number of people as gone
right and the reason it remained static
was because of
means in the 19th century and epidemics
and pandemics in the 20th century and
after independence what happens in my
lifetime Indian population has grown
more than four times
mainly because not because they could
give nutrition to the poor but they
could save their lives
thanks to you know medicine production
of true food agriculture irrigation of
Green Revolution all of those things
right and so in so so what was coming
into crisis for me was something that in
my head I it felt like I had solved like
I I could go back to Allatoona and say
look of course what you're saying is
right you know nature is not carved up
into these disciplines but there is a
benefit of carving it up if we act as
though nature could be so carved up then
we produce better standard of living and
isn't that important but suddenly to be
confronted with this question is it good
to improve go on improving the standard
of living of so many people you know and
I could not with my within my moral sort
of you know universe that I inhabited
and politics is a branch of morality
right moral thinking I could not answer
that question I mean that's why I was
saying it this genuine fear and
trembling when I'm faced with that
question so that's why I mark the sin is
a very interesting case in point you
know he's all he's devoted all his life
to thinking about welfare economics
right and thinking about welfare
thinking about what the normative
serology and framework of justice and
all of those questions and now when he's
faced with climate change and that was
using him a little bit to show the kind
of problems that sort of thinking runs
into and so what you do with the cow and
the human and the microbes and the
fractals is really what I was trying to
refer to as the idea of subject
dispersed and distributed over many life
forms and I was then saying once you
grant that kind of idea of subject
there's no corresponding I give the
political there's no corresponding idea
of God
and that's where la - I find la truly
struggling you know again he can create
the Action Network theory and then we
needs trying to create politics of
nature and think about it he with all
respect for him I Jim industry admire
him but I think there's a web of words
that he has to create he creates another
alternative world to which you can only
enter into it you can only enter after
you've taken language classes from him
and that's what his blosser he is doing
so you have to sit down with him because
he'll glean new acronyms and into the
book like you know inquiry into modes of
existence you folk you forget the
acronyms she'll go back to the glossary
all the time so you kind of constantly
taking tutorials from him as to how to
enter that that world right so and I
think I read that and my quandary is
symptomatic of of a high degree on
problem that cognition falls short of
the more immediate way in which moods
disclose the world to me and and
therefore it's very hard to create
politics out of cognition element and
that's why politics always has to come
back and appeal to read that more than
reason to affect to move to you know
persuading people is never just about
Commission so in a way so what I was my
falling into be history was about really
kind of the quandary of political
thought because I mean I can't aspire to
be a natural scientist but but I would
read that lieutenant I precise there
this is where your work and the big
history work are all partners in this
conversation but at the same time we
come from different projects into the
conversation right and so that's why I'm
trying to translate your responses back
to my concerns good thank you Michael
well I the notes I made last night begin
with a with a summary of my take of what
Depeche is trying to do in these
lectures and and so please forgive me
this might be slightly redundant to the
conversation we just had but I think
it's still good to be clear about what
the project is so two quotations from
yesterday's lecture to me really
illustrate the dilemmas that depeche is
trying to help us think through and the
first is the homo eccentric concerned
with justice represented by a March
essence remark that we need a normative
framework that should recognize that
growing need for energy consumptions by
humans if them if the masses of Africa
Asia and Latin America are going to
enjoy the fruits of human civilization
and to acquire the capabilities needed
for making truly democratic choices I'd
say that is a profound concern the
second is as oh eccentric one in his
language and and one quotation
illustrating it is the one that comes
from Vaclav SMIL if the billions of poor
people in low-income countries were to
claim even half the current per capita
harvest prevailing an affluent economies
too little of the Earth's primary
production would be left in it's more or
less natural state and very little would
remain for the men million species you
take those two concerns and put them
together and de peche sees that the that
reconciling these points of view is made
difficult by the fact that they do not
understand humanity in the same way and
cannot and I think that's the impetus
for coining these two terms homo and
anthropos we could substitute a
different scheme I think without
objection if you wanted to call it
humanity one and humanity two I think
the the point would be the same and de
precios question is who is that we we
are simultaneously a divided home
eccentric humanity and a dominant
species a part of the history of life on
this planet and a geological agent
with this collapsing of multiple
chronologies the human condition is
change and I think that the it's the
question of politics and ethics it's
thrown into disarray by that split
imagination of the human subject that I
think I take to be the center of these
lectures humanity to or the anthropos is
not a political or ethical subject
depressions language for it is quite
interesting climate change as ethical
consciousness then is constituted around
a split between the homo humanity as a
divided political subject and the
anthropos collective had unintended
forms of existence of the human now
collective and unintended as collective
is what inspires people to imagine a
global subject but unintended is what
inhibits that project so our language of
politics and ethics of personhood
responsibility and capabilities does not
figure the dispersed subject of humanity
- or the antipas unlike almost everyone
else who writes on this topic de peche
is engaging in a reflection that is
neither normative nor predictive and as
he says in the in the Q&A yesterday he
is asking for a space before I become
political I'd like to linger with him in
this project he does not write the kind
of wee sentences that characterized most
climate discourse and I've noticed that
those wee sentences tend to fall in two
different directions one is a kind of
directive steering sentence we must do
this we must reduce our population in
order to accommodate the carrying
capacities of the earth and it seems to
me that we sentences of that kind come
very naturally to climate scientists
because they inhabit the knowledge
subject that faces the extremity and
because they are Elise
whose knowledge is conditioned by
universities among other things and and
institutions of power in which it comes
naturally for it leads to think of
themselves as steering and if you read
love lock you see the really fascistic
potential of a lot of these we sentences
but of course there are we sentences on
the other side of the spectrum we
sentences that are trying to conjure for
us a global ethical subject one that
would be more responsive to a
multi-species world one that would be
post human and so on but that discourse
at least we have a lot of it in the
humanities that discourse to me is
beginning to look like to degree
thinking that is thinking predicated on
it on a two-degree outcome of global
warming over a long time frame in what
time frame do we expect a new global
ethical subjectivity to be ushered in by
North Atlantic intellectuals so I think
it it's really bracing that de peche has
asked us to stand back from both these
kinds of thinking and I thought it was
very telling in the Q&A yesterday when
you said if my argument is right it is
about the difficulty of being ethical
and the closest I get to an ethical
position is that of fear and trembling
similarly when one falls into big
history what unravels is the way one
thought about politics now so I would
like to ask a little more about politics
given what you said because the
alternatives are not simply the kind of
politics of care that would lead us to a
more ethical subject where everyone and
end to justice where everyone has the
same access to capabilities nor is it
entirely
Schmidt's friend versus foe
seems to me likely that whatever
politics we would like to have the
politics of climate change will continue
to be politics in the sense of
generating conflicting interests as much
as resolving them and organizing
resentments and struggles for mastery
under conditions of scarcity so if
anyone was following this story about
suppose water supply in the New York
Times a couple of days ago I think it it
bears and it casts a kind of disturbing
light on how these stories are likely to
occur in the future
you know SAP Paulo is facing a climate
change induced water crisis that's quite
extreme by our developed nation
standards and what struck me was the way
the the journalists had no trouble in
finding quotations like this one from a
finance manager of an art gallery
I feel hatred hatred of the governor and
sub s the utility company I'd like to
take them out and set fire to them they
completely failed to warn us and have
just continued to lie about this
throughout which of course may be true
yeah but you see my point that that a
lot of politics is people identifying
their resentments but rather than get
predictive and you know I don't want to
to say what will happen politically but
I would I would like to linger with
depression in this reflection or this
readjustment of our thought about what
politics means and in order to do this I
would like to invite us all to think
about the date cited for the beginning
of the Anthropocene July 16th 1945 what
had been the conditions of politics
since July 1945 well let me just name
three one is comparative peace one
doesn't have to think with Steven Pinker
that violence is disappearing to realize
that the the living generations in
developed countries have been able to
think of politics under condition
in in which wars are highly contained
often through proxies in places that do
not threaten domestic populations of
prosperous nations peace has been for
most of us are taken for granted and
under eyes condition of politics - and
related large and strong states this is
the era of welfare democraty democracies
and state capitalist regimes like China
and the former Soviet Union three
internationalism July 1945 is an
interesting date because in October 1945
the UN was founded and most of our
climate diplomacy and discourse is now
channeled to the UN so climate change
and our fall into big history may have
the effect of reinforcing these trends
especially the last one internationalism
but think about how the conditions of
human adaptation include political and
social institutions that will inevitably
be destabilized especially if population
contraction is envisaged and I think
that depression I similarly recoil from
the language of population contraction
as something that might be strategized
in this connection I think it's worth
remembering the point at de peche made
which is that humanity cannot survive
without the Technosphere without the set
of large-scale network technologies that
underlie and make possible rapid
extraction from the earth of large
quantities of free energy and and
long-distance communication and so on
one might even ask the question do we
have a responsibility to the
Technosphere since so much life depends
on it at this point and it's very
difficult to imagine any space any room
for manoeuvre in adaptation without it
the Technosphere is entirely dependent
on those strong states and some form or
another in capitalism I don't mean
market capitalism or liberal capitalism
China counts as a kind of state
capitalism in this respect so
just one more quote from de pasión then
I'll ask you know us ask us to think
about what we understand politics to be
in this world and it's our search for
climate justice and its attendant
politics may very well mean that we have
to travel the Via Dolorosa of dangerous
climate change
perhaps our struggles for climate
justice will have to be conducted in a
world that is even more climate stressed
and far more unjust than the one we have
at present thank you Michael
again thanks for the thoughts and and
III agree with everything you said the
the the coming world is going to make it
more difficult for us to be the kind of
ethical subjects the possibilities of
being ethical subjects that we found so
far entertained and you know the
compartments that we've had wanted to
assume even fuko's discussion of
ethically I think the coming world is
going to make it more difficult because
one is actually no longer placed within
bio politics and one is no longer
discussing the good life in the city and
what it should be like one is in the
larger realm of life of which we cannot
quite compose the politics yet or an
ethics life forms a clashing and said so
that's that I think is a completely
shared project and and the fact is that
the peace narrative that many of us have
grown up with in many parts of the world
not in every part of the world and some
parts of the world
I think people haven't grown up with
these narratives like in Israeli
Palestine but we have you know but not
just in the West but in China
in India and we've often felt very
grateful I mean my generation didn't see
depression
my father was without a job for six
years after his master's degree we
didn't see famine we had some war but
there were nearly border wars with China
and Pakistan was nearly never touched us
in that deep sense but is there there
are other places that have actually
people have grown up differently and I
think that's you know when the log when
the Charlie Hebdo thing happened I was
speaking to a Bangladeshi friend in in
England and he said to me he called me
the page table he's an older brother
figure in the Muslim person and he said
you know I came away from Bangladesh
Dharam where he lives and he said you
know I've been living here for 18 years
and in these 18 years only four or five
times perhaps busses have failed to come
on time in my 10 years I've assumed a
life where I go to the bus stop look at
my timetable and the bus comes where is
there are many people who don't have new
certainties in their lives and I
constant I keep on thinking by what
right can I hang on to this world of
certainty while majority don't have them
and at the same time but at the same I
said to him but the man it doesn't mean
that you desire that uncertainty because
you came to Dharam thinking of the
future of your children and you sort of
desire that certainty for there was two
and it's India I'm totally caught in
this but on the one hand I I realized
that this is the privilege for minority
for which I'm very grateful and have
joined the minority but at the same time
it seems unsustainable as there are more
people you know wanting to come in and
and this is something we all think
through so in some respects if the
tendency towards cutting the democratic
process short as you said is totally
built in to a lot of scientists thinking
so actually when the
Flannery wrote the first one of the
first popular books on climate change if
you call the weather maker weather
makers you'd see that weather makers
actually the chapter called carbon
democracy carbon dictatorship and I kind
of started the night team
you know carbon but you don't know about
dictatorship you know how can simply
talk about carbon dictatorship another
hand you know people have people who
come out of fascism of Nazism or the
Soviet Union or even other authoritarian
regimes have some idea of what it means
in everyday life as human beings so I
totally agree with you that that's where
the scientists social thought has to be
modified by my criticism but on the
other hand it is true that if you're
going to the politics of suppose we go
down that sad path of more climate
change and the flames test well and here
I find the debate about the answer
proceeding between climate or another
very instructive because the argument is
this you see even purely at the level of
technology if if we have enough time to
shift over to renewables before let's
say more than two degree warming sets in
the nations that will make more profit
out of the transition will not include
the United States the Chinese are much
more much more advanced with their
renewables technology selling them they
repeal the making them right solar
Chinese are you know very far advanced
selling them aggressively in places and
more cities think that you know one way
to solve the electricity problem is to
get away from the grid and have solar in
a rooftop and the Chinese are there
Americans lost the chance you know one
of the first elections the dream was
that the Americans would produce this
technology and sell it to the world
because of the close connection between
universities research and industries but
we miss that because we went for
fracking we went for other options right
for cheap energy so if if global warming
becomes an emergency like you know we
need to buy more time then we'll go for
geoengineering the country that has more
at its
disposal in terms of transition to
geoengineering is so geoengineering
actually is more a kind of strategic
it's more an argument in which very
powerful interest in America will be
invested because that way you also buy
time for the u.s. domination at me so
you think you will exactly right of the
of the planet tend for maintenance of
your life so there would be interesting
politics there but at the same time you
know when anthropologists in India have
studied childhood in middle-class
families like my kind of families
compared with childhood in slums
so they discover that you know the more
your resource endowed the more children
are actually socialized into being
declawed I mean your parents will don't
fight you know you stop fighting and
they find that in the slums parents in
they don't stop fights between kids
these kids will have to fight all their
life this fights over tap water you know
they fight over every resource is the
bring up children to actually fight when
I write what I read about Mughal history
the time you know I hate the Mughal
times because every two years there's a
war in this area that area if you're a
noble person in the court you had to
even before the book is within the
Muslim rule the wonderful historian who
writes about the old Peter Sultanate
period no ok adverse time and he was a
good poet and he realized that every
other noble was actually getting more
land grant making more money but he
wasn't and he asked people around so why
am I not getting promotion you know it's
like emotional system and people said
because you don't find you have to hold
the sword for the emperor you have to
wield the sword so this was the kind of
another system before the British came
him we're learning to killed was part
it's like the Knightly system was part
of being a gentleman part of me in a
district where was that you learned how
to kill and if you didn't you didn't go
up in the world and in some ways I think
if the world gets more straight
we will get less declawed so the
questions of civility all of those
things that we've come to value are at
stake and that's why it's pretty
important I think that we fight to keep
these values we fight as far as possible
for a more democratic solution to this
as we and that's why the homework
question will never go away right in
other words we because all of our values
that we know when this is this is
threatening civilization it's not just
monuments and the sea level rising but
it's actually threatening our values
it's threatening the values of peace
it's threatening what you how you want
to see fellow human beings all of these
things that's why I think that's why I
think it's better the same time as we we
cannot begin to even think about that
politics without acknowledging the
crisis for political thought trying to
take the very basic first step of
acknowledging the crisis against much
resistance because people people people
want to say that we already have those
you know we just have to go out but
there might be need for Mesa any
leadership there might be all kinds of
moments of political journey
so I guess I'm still speaking to my
microphone I I've revised my comments
somewhat in response to what we've been
talking about today and so I what I want
to start with really it's just the
observation absolutely this is a
situation in which vested interest in
many ways they are the ones the
dominating the conversation at this
moment and so the question is how do we
mobilize enough people so that there
could be a fighting chance for this not
to go entirely the other way so it's
really a question of the field being
dominated by vested interests and
various races being silent at the moment
so I want to think about this question
in terms of mass mobilization how do we
get lots and lots of people to get
involved and turn the question of
climate change into something with
enough mass momentum as Vietnam for
instance in the sixties right you know
that was a question there was the people
think about day and night you know it
was visible on the streets it was
visible in music and film in odd so you
know how to get climate change to have
that kind of magnitude so I wanted to
think about this in terms of three
questions one is visualization this is
something that depends about in this
lecture the climate change isn't
something that we can see it's not
something that we have a gut reaction to
us so how do we get climate change turn
it into something that is observable
within human optics I think the problem
is that human optics are not conditioned
to register something like climate
change because if facts are so far into
the future right you know the really
severe if that's 50 years into the
future
so our optics are not trained to observe
that kind of phenomenon so the question
is to turn what is unobservable into an
observable phenomenon and visualization
is crucial and I think that in some
sense it's also addressing Dan's
observations about you know how to turn
this into a kind of scalable problem
right you know it's right now with
departments that you know we're humans
we operate one scale and then climate
change and I'm oversimplifying your
point but climate change is really
operating on a somewhat different scale
you know it's the problem of
incommensurate scales so how to find
something that actually is observable on
our scales and I think that the best
candidate for that would be visual data
I think that you know from the
standpoint of evolution you know our
people certainly could see things a lot
for much longer time than they had the
language to talk about those things so
the linguistic register is grossly
inadequate register to think about
climate change we need to go back to
something that is there is more robust
foundation in terms of evolution which
is the visual so you know how to turn
climate change into a visual problem I
think that that's something that we need
to offers need to think about and so
that brings me to my second point which
is region I think that the question came
up yesterday that climate change is not
a departmental problem is now something
that could be tackled within a single
discipline and just the public
visualization especially some kind of
visual pedagogy that will enable us to
educate our students in such a way so
that they can actually see
thing where professors are not currently
equipped to do that kind of teaching you
know we need to know a lot more about
neuroscience to know the impact of
visual input you know what kind of input
this visual data half on recipients
that's something I know nothing about
you know I need to be retrained all of
us need to be retrained not just all
historians that need to know know about
visual operations but all of us do so
you know how how do professors retrain
themselves how do we we think you know
what students ought to be learning
what's to take away from each class you
know I think that we also need to think
about that you know we just go in
thinking that okay you know we just give
them all this stuff and that's the end
of it
that should just really give it at the
beginning to take away for each student
ought to be the self front and center in
the way that we think about education
and I guess related to that it's my
third question which is about
interactivity it you know I think that
at this point I think is is we really
need to to to take advantage of every
single medium that is at our disposal
and so the digital medium social media
you know anything else that comes up you
know we don't know what the next big
thing is you know but something
comparable to Facebook to anything you
know all of those things are to be part
of our conversation you know how to work
the question of climate change or use
those as the platforms to think about
climate change you know so how to think
about the digital medium at this present
moment and you know possible other media
in the future
thanks for those remarks in the game
them in spirit with you this one or two
responses on the question of
visualization which relates both to
optics as you said as well as to
concepts is like numbers I mean Dan
raise that question about how what
people do with numbers and how we sense
numbers were different between billion
and trillion then million those sort of
question then and the question of
training actually had very interesting
discussion over lunch yesterday about
training both graduate students
undergraduates and faculty and then had
some interesting ideas which I suppose
will come up in discussions about how
how do you create time within time and
opportunities within our present
structures for retooling but I think the
point is taken but let me begin with the
story about numbers it's an Indian joke
but the joke actually tells you
something about how numbers work in
popular consciousness when big numbers
and and don't and and of course when
people work with numbers even even
economic historians who work with
numbers and one set of numbers make make
sense because they relate to another set
of numbers so like he how many people
were killed in the Ukrainian famine in
Stalin's Russia is connected to history
of the labor market right so basically
how many people killed whether it was
eight million or you know twelve million
or whatever that will have some
significance if you're a student of the
labor market and supply of labor so
numbers relate to numbers but for most
of us we don't work with numbers numbers
take on other kind of significance so
the story but Indian civilization and
our pride in the ancient s of our
civilization that this Indian guy is
taking American tourists around and
points to a building and said you know
we're such an ancient civilization that
building there is three thousand and
four years
so the Americans you know I get 3,000
but where do you get the four I mean how
can you be so precise this is really
it's been four years since somebody told
me it was three thousand years old but
what it means that the three could have
been five three could have been seven
but we have a sense of ancientness so
there is a kind of non quantitative
sense of distance in time and proximity
in time where you know numbers can have
a sort of cultural plate in it so it
goes back to visualize this guy somehow
3000 appealed to him emotionally and you
know he could like our present prime
minister says that you know but it goes
back to the question the point I want to
respond to is that as you as you said by
tea that our optics are probably you
know hardwired for something else thinks
that but that the point I was trying to
make with big history and falling into
it is that you know during the Vietnam
War as you grew up which we grew up with
these questions of our evolution evolved
traits did not come up right the ways in
which people wrote poetry about Vietnam
and you know the photographs we're there
and you know some of these photographs
are actually sort of edged into our
consciousness but somehow the problem
was a fin nature where you wouldn't have
stood up and made that statement there's
a there's a different kind of crisis
where even somebody like you from
literature humanities background is
still you're living that you're living
in a situation where these ideas from
evolutionary biology or whatever are
swimming around us right so this
question comes up you know are we
because you know when you read about the
problems of visualizing climate change
you read about the Doppler effect you
read about whether our danger sensing
mechanism is so hardware that we sense
the danger only when it's completely
upon us but we don't see it's coming
incremental E
you know so problems of perceptions of
exponential changes so I'm just saying
that there for me that was an
interesting moment in what you say which
is really like this stuff has moved
close to us so if you think of thought
scape as a geologically right then you
use kind of as if it's as if the
continents have moved around I mean the
continent of evolutionary biology or
have what are we going to call it
evolutionary studies it's suddenly close
to the continent called humanity much
more close then it was in Vietnam crisis
and that for me is an interesting sense
just one going that one point that
Michael made before but yes I think I
think I totally agree with you I think
big history deep history are it I think
we were all swimming in it it's all
around us and I think that's when it's
wonderful to read then it's wonderful to
read the historian but I think the flip
side of it which sometimes comes up in
Dan's work not in the book so much but
in the introduction of its main volume
but it comes up even more clearly and
David Christian business sometimes
there's a position that somehow this is
ethically better or stronger and they
have a critique of subaltern not
supporting studies but you know like how
subaltern history brought back hey
Gideon ISM you have some lines which I'm
going to sometimes sit down with them
and critique but misses out on the
impact of construction is when
anti-alien it's about that studies but
but there is a kind of gesture that even
they make that this is somehow better
history and better as a better education
for us and so there is this claim of
being better as this thing from the
claim of saying look this is factually
true and these are two triple claims and
I think I think I find the first claim
more criticized but that we need to know
about these are these facts are in a
sense upon
I don't dispute in any anything so I
don't think I don't think we can do
without deep history of babies but the
the claims made inside those chains of
thought so which of you would like to
meet them well I noticed we've taken a
fair amount of time already well I
lots of three days in fact and so it's a
little bit difficult to know where to
begin I was thinking I was really struck
deep measured by what you said about the
sensation of falling into into big
history and and and the image of falling
is a really appropriate one because it's
not stepping into it as a floor yeah
it's a falling yeah
and that I think of that as a way of
explaining how there isn't any net or
structure to catch me with it when I
move into it the what what that made me
think of was this hope this whole point
about what happened to the extent that I
understand it in in European and
American culture in the 19th century or
even starting in the 18th century when
the the fact of deep time became right
and undeniable now if you look in in
certain kinds of writings especially
after the the banner year of 1859 when
three major volume come out that really
really now
if you look at the subsequent writings
of historians you get a sense that
they're all having this feeling it's
kind of this trauma of calling what
happened and this is what I've tried
this to scan job done is very well I
think it needs to be done by people who
are really really good at this kind of
work and I'm it's very nice Apple in it
but one of the solutions that they came
up with yeah
was to bracket the biological trust
absolute from the cultural past and and
they created that really hard line which
appeared in text books I think what
exactly that and Collingwood is the
climactic point of that yeah what
Collingwood is but but even more so it
it's it's Gordon child who creates the
Agricultural Revolution as the moment at
which history could be said to have
begun in some way so I see it I'm not
sure whether a fashionable word like
like trauma I find myself calling it but
I'm sure that's the right word because
there's a certain there's more of a
falling or of a sense of of nothing
being there to support me whether it's
traumatic or not I don't know coz if
some people's exhilarating so the the
really important thing I've ever read
wandering around around the subject but
the important thing was the way in which
this mind inserted itself in history it
is separated bracketed out biological
which was instantiated in into part
metal thinking in human evolutionary
biology and that made it safe that was
the way in which this trauma was
absolutely certain what but that
obviously is it's it's it's a major
cultural distinction this is something
option distinction is the maturing that
is when the tour is trying to get over
is only one point I would make is that
the title that Gordon child I don't need
to do it consciously but the title give
to that book is such a V Conan title
it's a peculiar way in which Vico sort
of suddenly turns up that's right you
know in a man makes himself and and
that's a phrase that Marx is using in
the eighteenth Brumaire saying
man makes himself but not in any which
way but in the circumstance in which if
that strand of vehicle running through
this going through Croce and then Croce
gets translated by calling wood and then
turning up into calling with philosophy
the idea of history that's right that's
right so what what you but you're doing
it but you that's not what you're doing
what you're actually doing is speaking
about them in ways where as you say big
history is right here with us is not a
type of history where it's bracketed all
right but that was where we're what I
was trying to say is to think of it in
terms of this fractal pattern right
actually is a friendly amendment because
actually I think the way which is you're
structuring it what you do is you you
think about the timescales but we don't
end up with just two we end up with this
constant linear cake which can take us
down to family histories of genealogies
the two had to do with my lingering
investment that you explained it really
well and it's a magnetic stirrer issue
whether or not it's real you know can I
say what about the fractal the way that
we can think about due time in terms of
kind of a fractal pattern and it goes
back to what you said about you know the
blurring of the boundaries between
Natural History and human history right
you know that that has been the norm for
historians is that you break it off
prehistory you bracket off ancient you
know pre pre linguistic history to some
extent and and say that's really not
part of the province of history which is
also another way of saying that Natural
Sciences are Brecon of the whole
foundation
the University it's based on the
separation between the Natural Sciences
in the human sciences and the humanities
and it seems that you know one way to
think about D time is actually to go
back to the point where those divisions
were not in place and and that actually
come brings us back to the question of
reorganization of knowledge and
restructuring of knowledge is that
actually at this point I think for us to
be to be adequate at what we're doing
you know mainly to be able to teach you
know my class in a way that is adequate
to the 21st century I do need to know
something about cognitive science
neuroscience I need to know something
about human physiology I need to know
something about a planetary the physics
engine physics of planetary processes
that's the baseline for a good professor
to teach the class in the 21st century
and I'm just absolutely not trained for
that you know that's not part of my job
requirement it's not part of my job
description
we're still looking for people you know
who are defining very traditional terms
that's not that's not doing us any good
so it really it's it's you know I think
that the consequences of rethinking the
separation between Natural History and
human history those consequences are
vast and and and they really cut at the
very foundation of the modern University
I couldn't agree more
Michael do you want to leave him briefly
before we open it out no I think we
should open it out all right
questions from from the floor there are
microphones on both sides please use
them if you if you want to ask a
question um I had a question about a
distinction that you didn't talk about
that has been in my mind recently
because I've been reading some recent
work by a keel builder ami about Gandhi
and Marx and and he talks Bill Rami
talks a lot about a commonality between
Gandhi and Marx and that they're both
working at diagnosing a process by which
we became alienated from nature and from
each other and a kind of common a common
modernity that was payoff for Bahrami is
this notion of an unalienable if-- of a
kind of a form of subjectivity that is
back in touch with certain kinds of
normative solicitations from nature that
we forgot how to look for when we became
kind of started to look at ourselves
from a third personal point of view
that's the kind of bill gourami line but
it's a line that's similar to I think I
kind of critique of scientific a
scientific understanding of language
that Charles Taylor's made and when when
you ended yesterday white like coming to
Heidegger I I kind of thought that you
were saying that something in the spirit
of those kinds of critiques of a kind of
third personal perspective on human
experience that we this this kind of new
predicament that were in forces us back
into a first personal condition of
roundest but but there's also in
addition to that first personal
experience the way I understood you to
be talking about the anthropos was that
we part of that condition is that we
have this third personal view on
ourselves and that we're forced to by
virtue of are things that we know about
the history of the planet which are
undeniable in a certain sense so on the
one hand it seems like I'm a little
confused because you seem drawn to this
this first personal language of throne
is but that that condition is partly
about this third personal observation of
ourselves I think I think I think the
question is is annunciated is it not can
can can you let him okay thank you thank
you
was it the book on Gandhi and Marx who
is that by Akhil Oh a kid named Tommy
okay yeah of course yeah well I mean
yeah I mean our kilts I mean I haven't
read the book I've read a couple of
chapters out of it when he was
publishing them as articles we're not
engaging with the climate crisis in any
way I mean oculus since been interested
in the climate crisis so so maybe in the
book it comes up more
now the one problem that I learned from
reading climate scientists and others
commenting on the current crisis is that
the god the that if you decentralized
the world economy which is what Gandhi's
vision would appear if you now
decentralized it and you know Gandhi's
on record saying I wish you know how
people say world has become very small
it's become like a village and Gandhi is
on record saying at which the world
would get bigger actually we'd have
population crashes is the argument is
that you can't support human population
on this scale by you know growing
vegetables in your backyard
so actually in anytime you have a
population increase the need for
accumulation goes up and and also to
manage a population as I was saying you
need larger energy consuming
bureaucracies that would simply keep the
population right well this connects with
the the issue that I was trying to raise
which is that most of our political and
ethical instincts right have to do with
some kind of repair and and the and the
dominant discourses in the humanities
Aquila's brilliantly synthesizing a
couple of them in those essays create a
kind of no longer viable vision I think
of rolling back some aspect or another
of modernity whether it's the whether
it's instrumental rationality whether
its growth capitalism whether it's the
technocratic administration of life
those have been the utopias driving left
criticism for a long time actually you
don't sue some of them they no longer
stay there just no longer seem to be on
the day some of this actually applies to
Bill McKibben as well at least in the
movie the you know he ends up it sort of
you know Jeffersonian plans or you know
so there's a long tradition of that
romantic vision right of going back to
nature in that I think you will
basically risk the lives a lot of people
if you did that
I wanted to ask for Michael and yg to
kind of bring their comments together
around one particular visualization
which is the Doomsday Clock and I'm
thinking about the July 1945 moment as
being in the immediate aftermath of
Holocaust historiography and liberation
narratives and in the immediate
prehistory of the atomic moment and it
seems like the atomic timescale and the
genocide timescales that have been
floated are thinking about catastrophe
up until the 1990s have now been
incorporated in a kind of messy or
uneven way into the timescales of
climate change and so I was wondering
whether you could think about the
implications or the inflections that the
atomic or the genocide will have upon
our risk calculation of climate change
as we linger in the pre political as
depeche has asked us so provocatively to
do well that's a huge question I don't
even know where to start with it but but
one thing to observe is that the the
alarm over nuclear arms created a lot of
the the structures of discourse that
we're still working with including that
global we have an anthropologist friend
named Greg Urban who did a brilliant
analysis of Jonathan shells book about
global nuclear disaster analyzing the we
and and and the there's a kind of
imaginary or a gentle way that gets
projected out of the spectacle of its
own destruction and that then organizes
all of his rhetoric well we're still I
think that's the origin of all the Wiis
sentences I've been noticing in climate
this horse but you're asking about the
timeframe because they're you with with
genocide and with nuclear war you can
imagine a kind of proximate punctual
event of danger and that's not what
we're looking at is that the question
yeah yeah right yeah yeah yes yeah well
and wait and and the disaster does not
affect the entire global population at
the same moment or at the same rate or
in the same way so right but in terms of
the time scale though those are
instantaneous right you know I mean the
Holocaust is so visualizable all you can
show is the teeth you know from you know
I mean in fact it's completely cinematic
likewise the atomic bomb I mean you know
even in a non visual representation like
John Surtees Hiroshima that is a
completely visual tax because you can I
mean it met its naturally visual in a
sense that you can see the skin you know
ripping up the bodies and also it's
instantaneous so the time frame is
actually very very short and if those
were the two things that could be called
global catastrophes the conditioning our
conception of of catastrophe right now
then those are really inadequate models
I mean I think that's what you're
getting at is that you know we are so
used to thinking in terms of the
Holocaust in terms of the atomic bomb
that we really need to recondition
ourselves to think about something that
is you know say 50 years ahead but some
countries have already done that the
Netherlands has done that you know and
because half this country is going to be
underwater
you know if the sea level rise or to
proceed you know even though the
extremely conservative wait you know so
they are actually doing their planning
for 50 years how they're relocating the
populations right now you know they're
being compensated but there's no option
for them not to be able o cated in the
Netherlands so that's one country it's
very very serious respond to something
that is completely not visualizable at
the moment and I think that because the
Netherlands has been so historically
used to water as
as something that you need to live with
that there's no way to run away from it
there's no way to look away from it it's
just kind of non-human fact that you
know that human beings have to weave
into the human calculations and I don't
think that we have we're currently in
that frame of mind so that's why I do
think that their education has it has it
has a role to play because if the
Netherlands I mean it's not as if there
are different species of human beings
they're just human just like us it's
just they've been reeducate it you know
to accept water as a daily fact of life
you know it's probably very rational
calculus and we are not in a habit of
doing that it just do actually connect
it up with you the question I didn't
answer the second question but going
back to what what you were saying one
problem with global warming is that
there is not yet an emergent shared
global chronology of the warming first
of all you don't know you have scenarios
there's no certain one scenario when the
warming might go which way right and
secondly if countries who are applying
the narrative of growth to the narrative
of global warming so just as India would
say okay it's now our turn to grow and
later on we'll say it's now our turn to
have global warming right you guys are
having global warming in the West but
you know we're not really having it oh
it's not an issue right so it's you know
we unlike the Vietnam War again
- can I ask you a question you talked
about this from the point of view of
India right in the lectures well India
is now facing a wave of displaced people
from Bangladesh and they're militarizing
their border and like most developed
countries their military has a plan for
securitizing climate change yeah so well
but public level it becomes a discourse
about illegal immigrants I'm sorry in
the public level in the aplex fear it
becomes a discussion about illegal
immigrants so in this actually buying
border controlling technology from
Israel
is is that it's our turn to grow is that
to degree thinking and it's it's it you
know it's almost sort of no degree
thinking like oh the great it's like it
it is not the Indian it was every day
it's not an issue it comes up when Paris
comes up for Copenhagen comes up and
then there are few op eds saying we must
insist on the differentiated responsive
in school these guys have to pay but
what I'm saying is the going to your
first question is that so
my point was really what is I was not
about the general human condition I was
drawn of the human condition as a
subject for thinking for thinkers of you
know kind of people have people to think
about history human history so I was
Michael Sata I was asking for a going by
a Spurs I was asking for a space within
which to think because because I think
while there are this political the
important statements being made it's
clear that many governments of countries
that matter see one-fifth of humanity
actually emit ninety percent of
greenhouse gases about 12 to 14 nations
amid ninety percent of you know India
and China included most nations and not
emitters now even within the emitter
nations some powerful countries like
India don't want to take responsibility
even at a national level so so you can
see how difficulty needs so like in like
will train here will create other kind
of awareness and sheer some students
will come from South Asia pick it up but
it's a very slow process of that
percolating back I now go back to India
and I now find people who have read my
climate peace which actually an Indian
general refused to publish when I first
wrote you know they said it's not its
own you're not addressing our issues so
there's all the collage in global time
thanks for the discussion which is
fascinating
um may be against the grain of my own
intuitions and the point that yeah I
think made in the lectures extremely
convincingly let me suggest a way or few
ways in which I thought you also
mentioned moments in which the two
positions that clash might actually be
brought together on a different level so
even when you emphasize the role in
which our agency is both intellectually
and practically undermined by its
exercise there still seems to be a
moment in which you insist in which the
homo centric view has not just kind of a
traditional habit is that we need to get
rid of but is actually intellectually
justified in as far that we are aware of
the agency that we have undermining
itself so there is a self reflexivity
that does mark us out which is then
exactly the point that i guess makes you
comfortable and insisting on the
homeless centric view as deeply ethical
and politically not just out of
conventionality but out of an awareness
and difficulty of the situation to win
so I wanted to ask if that if that is
the case theoretically what would be the
right level for thinking that to get
though of justifying homeless centric
view not out of traditional reflexes but
out of a new awareness that could
justify it and then maybe more
practically there were moments when you
dressed you towards like new ways of
conceiving of our mastery of species and
the world and you dismissed them mostly
by reference to technological limits the
difficulty of knowing how we affect
other species but are there also
intellectual limits to this what is what
is your take on that kind of option so
basically what I was doing was yes I
there is for many this cognitive
awareness that country so that's what I
was bringing Heidegger in to say that
why cognition falls short of politics
because what he called smooth intervene
and as I was saying
we have to take denial seriously as a
human response skepticism seriously as a
human response so in effect you can't
create a politic denying these moods
right I mean you might want to defeat a
denialist but you have to acknowledge
their presence or you have to then you
know understand what nihilism does so
that's why that's why I was trying to
argue that following Heidegger that that
cognition even though I've fallen into
the history then I encounter all these
moods and of course the Zoe centrism
puts even the moods question in question
because the subject of the Zoe centric
view whether I was following the
disperse the subject dispersed over
multiple species right and and the
second question is - what I mean that is
also the Lateran question you know how
do you compose something that involves
these not just even species so the one
question I was raising was about viruses
which are considered like between living
and non living entities but we'd have an
impact on life if that's where I think I
don't have an answer I mean that's the
question I agree the better with the
question and that's where I was thinking
that okay if we recognize that as part
of the space I'm calling a focal
consciousness then then what one is
doing is what Michael did beautifully
actually a very contradictory move you
are asking for patients when faced with
an emergency right and because what
happens is you don't ask for patients
then I find as a thinker all the old
habits of thought are rushing to take
the place of that which needs to be
thought
but aren't you also saying that I mean I
think that you are in fact talking about
a level of human agency that needs to be
reaffirmed at this moment right you know
that kind of homo centric paradigm is
not to be disband yeah I mean if we
could dispense it then the problem would
be even worse because this question what
can we do what do we do is an insistent
human question I don't think this in the
same way that there's no getting away
from denialism in the same way there's
not a getting away from this question
what can we do but you see in India the
national mood is one of denial there's
not so much of skepticism or of
indifference it's just a means question
and this is why it's not that I think
what depression is really challenging us
to is not just thinking about how we can
mobilize its intense questions and it
Maps actually to a large degree on the
debate among climate scientists about
whether we are trying to save the earth
from humans or for humans right and and
really that that's an irresolvable
problem right that's an unusual problem
that's why it sort of greens political
responses into a deep sense of crisis
but on the other hand faced with anybody
it's not like you don't do you do things
I don't have it so you know in a way
what has happen is political thought has
become habitual thought and sometimes my
problem with talking to you know Max's
friend or whatever is to get them to see
that they're doing habitual thinking it
doesn't actually think
thank you very much so I see that this
crisis you may have fallen into big
history but environmentalists have been
pushed into politics and economics and
so we have started to reimagine our
environmental problems as mismanagement
as market failures and the solution is
then routed in this management discourse
and you know bringing in externalities
and what we kind of envision is a design
nature that is friendly to other species
but while ultimately serving our own
aims and you know eco-friendly shopping
and all these very individualistic
things so we have this paradox where we
are both the makers of the earth but
also at the mercy of our mistakes much
like in Adam Smith's perfect market we
are both you know the individual actions
kind of create this larger the larger
system so I it strikes me that the
Anthropocene is a very neoliberal
project and I was just curious I mean
I'm the answer person has a deep
connection to neoliberal project if
you're dating it from post 45 so even
the great acceleration thesis is about
the neoliberal economy so if you follow
the curves they the the rise in
consumption and the rise in emissions
all have to do with opening up of
economies and and the connection between
economies so in that sense in that sense
you're totally right but on the other
hand we're an economic expansion as I
was saying meets his limits is that the
planet needs to do things for us to be
nice for sale in other words when you
date Anthropocene from how much the
planet warms depends on many earth
processes of which you don't have
economic explanations so that's why I
always say that you know it's economic
its economics plus it's and what happens
with economists who do risk modeling
they mainly stay with the physics of it
so which is why I think they can you can
build stable scenarios you can say to
degree rise this is the impact four
degrees rise this is the impact right
and you can't model for the tipping
point because it's partly Ciotti you
Atlee unknown what the the people who do
mainly risk modeling don't dream so much
is valiant Valley the paleoclimate
logical evidence so for instance the
evidence that comes out of geologists
studying off what's called the PETM
event of 55 million years ago right when
the temperature went up by 8 degrees
over 10,000 years now they don't prime
it modules are sometimes treat that but
see so the geologists more like
historians they know as all that would
say so they have an archive and they go
and read that archive and in a sense
their problem is that as the world gets
more and more modified the archive
changes in other words the archive is so
they still going to a world unmodified
by human beings in order to understand
previous episodes of climate the
planetary war it's possible that as we
modify the planet that archive will be
lost but anyway that's what they they
they do and actually the risk modelers
don't go into that because those are
most of geological evidence of tipping
points are about climate disasters and
as I said you can make policies for
disasters so and then there's the the
biological thing and the deep connection
between Earth processes and life
processes you know which Lovelock was
trying to get at and now if you brought
all of those things then I don't think
it's a need it's merely a neoliberal
construct but that our emissions have
gone up with with the with the global
economy becoming nearly broke you know I
think that there's no dispute about that
I mean the curves all show that ok we
were you asking whether the whole
thought of the Anthropocene isn't
neoliberal figuration because
wait yeah wait yeah yeah
right yeah yes sorry yeah well that's I
I would like to hear you talk a little
bit about the long present because
there's a between the new liberal like
come in your document again can you
explain it well she's pointing out the
ways that I mean I I wouldn't read that
it would Smith as neoliberal so what
were what what tends to be the
assumption in this conversation is that
we're talking about how to adapt our
minds and and the organization of our
society to this long DeRay future okay
so as to stave off four degrees or
whatever and that it kicks in a kind of
managerial temporalities that is rooted
in individual choices and may nice the
maintenance of this kind of freedom and
the maintenance of the space that
Foucault calls security for the minimal
steering of actions through fear right
and I think that's that's the sense in
which a lot of even radical discourse
about the Anthropocene seems continuous
with that with the continuous with
discussions of individual choice and is
that put here is that what you meaning
managerial yes yeah yeah yeah no I'm not
there but for which you can see there I
mean what other can you just name a
couple of things there will be
alternatives to the managerial motto
yeah
yeah yeah but I was just thinking you
know I think oh just two quick responses
you know one is that I mean it's
interesting like so when you read older
books on environmentalism or
environmental thinking you know how
environmentalist would often talk about
the goodness curve which you got to
pollution right that Piketty makes so
much oh so you you pollute and then you
become rich enough to sort of take care
of the pollution and of course there is
no goodness curve in climate change you
know the richer you get the cleaner you
get you might actually have a worse
gravity and the second problem I think
which goes probably more to the heart of
what we're saying is that see the reason
why ultimately the discipline of if the
display of economics even if it if it
ever came to terms with costs of
externalities pricing externalities and
not just for pollution but also for
climate and all those things I mean then
it'd be very clear that the kind of
affluence we now have would be
unmaintainable in other words see at the
moment say with coal production there's
you know the state picks up the tabs or
insurance company you know they pick up
the tabs on the health cost so a lot of
industrial production I mean like a lot
of people argue that cancer is
unavoidable with what industrial
societies produce right and and it's
kind of a trade-off between managing
cancer and and having the benefit of the
creature comforts we have in our life so
if we were to actually price all of
those things and actually extended the
market principle to all problems all
domains of human life it would work I
mean we'd have a crash of three economy
and in that sense I I agree but all but
there's an interesting debate in the
climate literature argument coming from
an older debate actually about moral
choices where the argument is precisely
and
somebody mentions they'll Jameson yes
sir but others have made this point that
actually you cannot and here's the
problem of democracy as we think of it
democracy's booth at the individual
consumer level at with as well as in
terms of electoral cycles are not
systems suited to address questions very
long-term questions like climate change
and whereas if you think of the last 50
years the history of decolonization the
history of decolonization is actually a
history of more democratization of first
I think I can I think I can refresh you
miss question there's a way in your
first lecture about Jasper's an
extremity ring you use the language of
extremity and danger you did not use the
language of risk and and I think that
that's the the that sort of pinpoints
the danger because risk is one of these
objectifying management particular
projecting modes of thought it comes
naturally to people in developed
societies not to think of everything in
terms of risk but danger is a very
different cost and danger does not
rounded routed through probabilities
it's not objectified it's not scalable
over long histories its present or it's
not and that's why I did cite or did
mention Weitzman with the only economist
whom I've actually read on climate
science who actually says that risks are
best made for low risk scenarios
I mean policy is the best mate but low
risk an area so he actually says the
Dean inherent bias in the description
literature in favor of low risk
scenarios and therefore that's why when
it comes to danger of tipping points the
catastrophic climate change is something
they can't make policy for widows from
this policy base
or managerial mono I think that's what
you're asking for is if we can think not
in terms of cost-benefit analysis which
i think is still to some extent you know
invoking move away from the cost-benefit
analysis or putting a value on you know
ecotourism or something like that but
things of it
think of it in terms of something that
people wouldn't would have a
instinctively do I mean I think that
what it's interesting is for instance
for its kind of uncool at this moment I
mean some people still do but for large
segments of the population it's uncool
to wear fur whereas that wasn't the case
you know just a generation ago so to
have that kind of personal this case you
know for something that's actually also
ecologically politically incorrect but I
think that it's good to have that kind
of you know a pattern of this taste in
loss of us so that you know we actually
have you know if in fact you know cows
including 18 percent of green house gas
then for us to ever this stays for beef
you know how could that come about that
I would say it's something that is
actually outside the scope of a
managerial project it is it is something
else and there's no name yet for you
know what kind of education would
actually generate habits at this pace
but that would be one possibility but
can I just please have not all manager I
mean like for instance if the government
made the decision to actually have more
public transport and actually make it
difficult for a you know it make it
easier for us not to have to rely on
individual transports I mean those would
be political questions and it's clear in
many instances that you know we need to
have more public transport but we need
to have fewer cars and their neoliberal
economy militates against that kind of
public choices
right
no I was simply making the point with
that I mean this is that if you have
more people then even if you had a non
liberal bureaucracy you need a larger
bureaucracy to manage the population and
that was my my argument being that
irrespective of how energy is
distributed internally in a society more
people means you need more energy you
know how you consume it is a different
question of justice okay there may be
time for one more thank you I enjoyed
your talk yesterday in this conversation
I miss your first lecture I have
actually two questions you can answer
either of them well how do we engage in
a conversation about what I I guess
might call cult of growth everybody's
for growth which is just a euphemism for
more per capita consumption at a point
with our obligations that we may feel
about the size and the living standards
of future generations what can be the
terms of that conversation the second in
geological time that you talked about
will the climate change or even the
human species appear anything as
anything more than a barely detectable
we could almost stop right there right
yeah I do the second question is perhaps
really more easily answerable in the
sense that if you took the view that we
are a blip which we are see there is no
climate problem without concern it's
only because you feel concerned about
other human beings that you feel that
problem in other even somebody who
thinks we should think of life before
humans like Lovelock does when he says
but we need to think good life before
humans so that humans can actually
sluggish so that humans don't harm
themselves so it's that's why I was
saying that well the moment we talk were
dangerous climate change we're actually
speaking morally we are not speaking
just scientifically but but I have
rained geologists who say that you know
this will not lead to extinction of life
maybe future geologists will come and
say ok here was an event that we will
name as a boundary event between a
geological epoch and you know in the
Holocene ending and like the dinosaurs
are meant to have gone out you know you
know that Markus KT extinction right the
KT is about the borderline and this will
come and give it a name now but if you
only read it like that there would be no
there'll be none of this discussion
right it comes because as I was saying
one cares one feels committed to fellow
you including future generations that's
going to answering a perscription is a
very good book actually by a philosopher
called Stephen Gardiner it's called a
perfect moral storm and it takes up this
whole question of the care of you care
for future generations and actually goes
through a whole lot of examples and
discussions to show why it has become
such a difficult question within the
climate problem that's why he says it's
a perfect moral storm for a philosopher
and the chapter on cost-benefit analysis
in that book is called
it would be presumptuous of me to try
and end this conversation by summing up
what has been an extraordinary rich
studied interventions and views and
conversations and and wonderful
wonderful lectures it doesn't seem to me
that that that that the that one of the
challenges that you issued yesterday
very very clearly and one of the words
that you used has been we have hovered
around it but nobody has used the word
this morning and that is personhood and
the challenge the challenge of
ultimately you know it founds everything
from Liat neoliberal institutions to to
to our politics and so on and so forth
and you know the inadequacy the other
word that rings for me is then that is
inadequacy inadequacy of our modes of
thought the inadequacy of our projects
and so on to cope with a challenge that
requires us to think personhood in
fundamentally different terms and this
this this - for you to have laid this
out in in ways that humanists and
scientists alike that can facilitate a
conversation that can get richer and
richer on this campus between humanists
and scientists alike is a huge
achievement and I want to thank you I
want to thank all of our panelists